how can you argue that racism is not a
driving factor in income inequality
because it has nothing to do with race
and everything to do with culture and
when you have a culture that doesn't
and when
you know what explain to me you explain
to me why black kids aren't graduating
high school explain that one to me
explain to me why black kids are
shooting each other in rates
significantly higher than whites are
shooting each other explain me why 13 of
the population is responsible for 50 of
the murder explain to me why the why the
number of blacks and black kids in
prison not for innocent reasons not for
walking down the street and getting
pulled into a prison is so high explain
if it has nothing to do with culture
explain to me why the single motherhood
rate in the black community jumped from
20 to 70 percent in the same course of
time that the civil rights movement has
made such tremendous strides is america
more racist now than it was in 1960 and
if it is please explain to me how that
happened